the division resurgence at this
admittedly early stage feels different
it may not enjoy the graphical fidelity
of its console counterparts but
everything else about the game makes it
look like a proper entry into the
franchise as opposed to a spin-off with
a mobile asterisk
gamespot recently got to see the game in
action and speak with the executive
producer fabrice neverez and our look at
the game suggested the division
resurgence has the same mechanics and
gameplay as its console and pc
counterparts
resurgence is a third person loot
shooter that offers cooperative gameplay
as well as competitive gameplay in an
open world new york city just like the
division one resurgence is fully
canonical to the world of the division
it begins concurrently with the division
1 which affords an opportunity to show
some of the events at the beginning of
that game from a new perspective
benavrez says the bulk of the game takes
place after the story events of the
division 1 so it also serves as kind of
a pseudo sequel the main enemy in
resurgence is a faction new to the
division's universe they are called the
freeman and they are made up of
scientists craftsmen and engineers who
are trying to survive in new york city
what makes this group different from
previous enemy division factions is not
yet clear but you will be fighting them
for the first time on mobile the third
person shooting gameplay looks a lot
like what's on offer in the other
division games you take cover behind
anything you can on dilapidated streets
and use various abilities to get an edge
over the enemy
but with some compensations and
adjustments made for the mobile platform
at the beginning of the game you can
choose your specialization or class and
over the course of the game you unlock
different specializations that you can
swap between
for example the vanguard specialization
can highlight enemies for your team to
see and the demolitionist can use seeker
mines to take them down among other
explosive weapons six specializations
will be available at launch in the
gameplay showcased we saw players
throwing up cover to get into better
shooting positions and dropping enemy
turrets to help against enemies the
freemen are also well equipped and can
use items like remote controlled drones
the new york city featured in resurgence
is open world according to ubisoft the
missions you tackle within it are split
between main missions world events and
other activities
resurgence also includes a version of
the dark zone the division's player
versus player end game area built
specifically for mobile as well as the
franchise's skirmish and domination
modes for competitive players
resurgence also features customizable
user interface and control options
allowing for multiple setups for using
the touch controls
navrez made it clear the development
team spent a lot of time focusing on
touch controls to try and deliver an
experience that feels comparable to the
console and pc games but resurgence will
also offer full controller support
limited only by your mobile device's
options you can use bluetooth
controllers or controllers that plug
directly into your phone navra said
ubisoft's goal for the game is to have
basic parity with the first two division
games and for it to be welcoming to
established fans or new players
but the three games are being treated as
standalone experiences
resurgence is a fully independent game
which means at least initially we
shouldn't expect any overlap between the
division games
unlocks in one game won't apply to the
other
but that is something navra says could
be considered in the future
the big question lingering about
resurgence
which will be free to play when it
launches
is how its monetization works
navrez was not able to specify how
you'll be able to spend money in
resurgence but he did share ubisoft's
intentions this is from navrez what
matters the most for us is to make sure
resurgence is a game everybody can play
compete and enjoy in a fair manner and
so that's really the cardinal rule we
have there is to make sure that
everybody can enjoy the game at their
own pace and we know it's always a
sensitive question for the community and
that's why later we will come back with
more details but we are very confident
that we'll find the sweet spot and the
right balance to make sure that
everybody will enjoy the game when
player concerns about pay to win
monetization schemes were brought up to
navrez he reiterated his previous point
focusing on ubisoft's intention to make
the game as fair as possible
one element of the division resurgence
that neither the division one nor its
sequel had to contend with was the
prospect of making a game about a
pandemic during a pandemic the division
resurgence began development in 2018 and
will be entering a closed alpha soon
which means the bulk of its development
happened and continues
while the world still deals with the
covet-19 pandemic
the universe of the division is fiction
navarez is quick to remind and was
created in a pre-pandemic era but there
is no denying the resonance of the story
in the face of current world events
here's what navara says i think that the
key for us here is that we embrace what
we've built in regards to the world
established by the first two games the
gap between mobile games and console and
pc games is getting smaller and smaller
the division resurgence is
optimistically proof that third-person
shooters can fit on a different type of
platform there are still questions
lingering about resurgence primarily how
the game will be monetized and if it
will be in a way that negatively affects
the experience but our early look leaves
us hopeful that it will be a worthwhile
experience especially for fans of the
first two division games
you